>> Dana: I'M DANA PERINO ALONG
WITH KIM LEGAL FILE
-- THIS IS "THE FIVE."
ALL RIGHT.
SEE THE CLOCK ON THE BOTTOM
RIGHT OF YOUR SCREEN?
THAT'S HOW MUCH TIME IS LEFT FOR
THE SENATE TO AVERT A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
DOWN TO THE WIRE IN LESS THAN
SEVEN HOURS, THE HOUSE PASSED
EXTENSIONS, BUT DEMOCRATS ARE
INCLUDING PROTECTION FOR YOUNG,
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS.
LITTLE PROGRESS.
AROUND ON BOTH SIDES.
>> I WISH FOR ALL OF OUR SAKES
THAT THE DEMOCRATIC LEADER WOULD
FIGURE OUT WHAT HE ACTUALLY
WANTS.
SPEAK WITH THE BEST THAT THE
ROAD LOOKING LEADER IN THE
SENATE IS ANOTHER BAND-AID,
ANOTHER FOUR WEEKS OF TEMPORARY
EXERCISE.
AND HE KNOWS IT.
>> WHAT THEY ARE SIMPLY TRYING
TO DO IS HOLD ALL OF GOVERNMENT
>> DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN WILLING
AND READY TO SIT DOWN AT THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE TO REACH WITH
OUR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES.
BUT WE WILL NOT BE BLACKMAILED.
>> Dana: JESSIE, I'M GOING TO
YOU FIRST.
THERE'S NOTHING IN THERE THAT
YOU DON'T AGREE WITH.
WHY NOT GO AHEAD AND DO THAT AND
WE'LL KEEP TALKING TO YOU ABOUT
THE OTHER STUFF?
>> Jesse: I'M JUST BORED BY
THE WHOLE THING.
WE ARE $20 TRILLION IN DEBTS, WE
DO THIS EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
WE SPEND MORE AND MORE MONEY ON
THIS GOVERNMENT AND IT DOES
LEFT.
LESS.
SOMETIMES YOU SHUT IT DOWN,
NOTHING HAPPENS.
YOU THINK THAT WE REALLY NEED IT
QUITE LIKE THE DEMOCRATS THINK
THEY HAVE LEVERAGE HERE BECAUSE
THE POLLS ARE OBVIOUSLY GOING TO
PUTTING DREAMERS OVER THE
PAID, FIREFIGHTERS ARE NOT GOING
TO GET PAID, POSTMEN ARE NOT
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO WAKE UP ON
SATURDAY IF THEY SHUT THIS DOWN
AND SAY, OKAY, HOW DOES THIS
AFFECT ME?
EVERY YEAR WE GET INVOLVED IN
THE SILLY DRAMA.
THESE POLITICIANS PULL US INTO
THE SILLY DRAMA AND EVERYBODY
WITH THE COUNTDOWN CLOCK, IT'S
RIDICULOUS.
I'M SICK OF IT.
>> Kimberly: YOU'RE GOING TO
REGULAR COMPANY -- IT WOULD
NEVER HAPPEN IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
SAYING THAT EVERY DEMOCRAT
SENATOR WHO IS RUNNING FOR
REELECTION IN A RED STATE, THEY
SHOULD HAVE ADS RUN AGAINST HIM
THIS WEEK AND THAT SAY "YOU ARE
CHOOSING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS OVER
INSURANCE PROGRAMS."
HE COULD'VE PASSED THE CHIP
PROGRAM, THE CHILDREN'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PROGRAM.
YOU HAVE A REPUBLICAN IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, REPUBLICAN HOUSE,
THEY CANNOT PASS A BUDGET.
WE COME BACK TO THE ARGUMENT
ABOUT THE DREAMERS.
YOU HEAR -- JESSE REACTED TO
THIS.
"OH, IT'S ABOUT THE MILITARY."
IT'S ALL ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
CAUSING CHAOS AND PEOPLE DON'T
KNOW HOW TO DEAL WITH IT BECAUSE
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
EVEN KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IT IS
THAT DONALD TRUMP IS WILLING TO
SIGN HERE.
THEY THOUGHT THEY HAD A DEAL.
>> HE'S GOING TO SIGN THE
PACKAGE, JUAN.
>> Juan: SURE HE IS.
>> Jesse: HE NEEDS 60 VOTES!
>> Juan: LET ME JUST SAY.
>> Jesse: WHO DID THEY VOTE
FOR IN THE HOUSE?
80% OF AMERICANS SUPPORT THE
DREAMERS.
DONALD TRUMP, THE PRESIDENT --
>> Greg: THAT SHOULDN'T BE A
DEADLINE!
>> Greg: IT'S NOT PART OF THE
SPENDING THING.
THEY SAY THEY HAVE A HOUSE, THE
SENATE, WE KNOW YOU NEED 50
VOTES.
LET'S KILL THAT ARGUMENT.
I WILL SAY THIS.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHO TO
BLAME.
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN POWER
WHEN IT HAPPENS, IT'S THE
REPUBLICANS.
WHEN THE REPUBLICANS ARE IN
QUITE LIKE IT'S THE REPUBLICANS'
FAULT.
I WILL SAY THIS ABOUT THE
REPUBLICANS FOR THE INTERIOR
DEPARTMENT AT THE SAID DO NOT
NEED STAFFING.
YOU CAN STILL HAVE THE OPEN AIR
DON'T NEED STAFFING.
UNLIKE OBAMA, THEY DIDN'T, LIKE,
USE BARRICADES TO SCORE
EMOTIONAL POLITICAL POINTS WHICH
MAKES ME THINGS MAY BE
REPUBLICANS ARE BETTER PEOPLE.
>> Dana: KIMBERLY, EARLIER
BASICALLY AND IT WAS VERY STARK.
THIS IS WHAT HE HAD TO SAY ABOUT
THE SHUTDOWN.
>> IT'S GOT A HUGE MORALE
IMPACT.
I WILL JUST TELL YOU.
HOW LONG CAN YOU KEEP GOOD
PEOPLE AROUND WHEN SOMETHING
LIKE THIS HAPPENS?
THERE IS ALWAYS A QUESTION
THAT'S GOT TO HOVER IN THE BACK
OF MY MIND.
I WOULD JUST TELL YOU THAT WE DO
AROUND THE WORLD AND IT COSTS
MONEY.
THOSE WOULD STOP.
>> Dana: K.G.?
>> Kimberly: THE LAST THING
YOU WANT TO DO, AS JESSE
MENTIONED, THE MILITARY I CHEER
FOR, WHEN YOU SEE A SITUATION
LIKE THIS AND YOU HEAR SOMEONE
SPEAK ABOUT IT LIKE GENERAL
MATTIS, THE ONE THING YOU NEED
TO
UNITED STATES MILITARY.
IT'S SUCH POLITICAL
GAMESMANSHIP.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN SEE IF
THERE.
IT'S FRUSTRATING BECAUSE THEY
SHOULD PUT THROUGH SPENDING.
THERE'S NO NEED TO GO THROUGH
THESE TYPE AND MACHINATIONS.
NEVERTHELESS, THEY PERSIST.
DANNA: OUR ENEMIES, THIS IS WHAT
MATTIS WAS TALKING ABOUT,
THEY ARE FULLY FUNDED.
THEY CAN PLAN WELL AHEAD.
WE ARE SUPERIOR, BUT WE'VE GOT
TO STAY ON TOP OF THINGS.
>> Greg: IT GOES BACK TO THE
INITIAL POINT.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE WILLING TO
SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT OVER A
POLITICAL CAUSE.
THEY ARE WILLING TO THROW OVER
ONE GROUP OF MINORITIES FOR
ANOTHER GROUP OF MINORITIES IF
IT SERVES THEM POLITICALLY.
THAT IS CALLING IT THE SCHUMER
SHUTDOWN.
IT'S A SMART MOVE.
ALLITERATION TRUMPS EVERYTHING
WHERE THEY LEFT TRIED TO --
WHAT, THEY WERE CALLING
DONALD TRUMP DONALD DRUMPF?
IT DIDN'T WORK.
REPUBLICANS, BUT I'M GOING TO
ASK YOU, PRESIDENT
-- NEITHER OF THEM REVEALED WHAT
WAS SAID IN THE MEETINGS.
THE ONLY THING SCHUMER SAID THAT
THERE WAS PROGRESS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THEY TALKED
ABOUT?
>> Jesse: THEY COOKED UP
SOMETHING WHERE TRUMP COMES IN
AND SAVES THE DAY OR SCHUMER
COMES IN AND SAVES THE DAY.
THEY'RE DOING RIGHT NOW IS THE
EXACT SAME MAKE USE REPUBLICANS
SHUTTING DOWN THE GOVERNMENT FOR
SOMETHING TOTALLY UNRELATED TO
THE BUDGET --
>> Dana: A LOT OF REPUBLICANS
SAY ULTIMATELY THE SHUTDOWN HELP
>> Juan: PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
RIGHT NOW AND THINKING, THIS IS
ON TOP OF WHAT JESSE IS SAYING,
WHY DOES THE GOVERNMENT ALWAYS
GET IN THE SITUATION?
THE WHITE HOUSE DIRECTOR SAYS
THIS IS A DYSFUNCTIONAL CONGRESS
THIS IS A DYSFUNCTIONAL CONGRES
CONGRESS.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT THAT.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING, YOU MEAN
REPUBLIK IS A DEMOCRATS FOR!
OBVIOUSLY.
>> Dana: IT WOULD BE GREAT IF
>> Juan: I JUST CAN'T TAKE --
YEAH, WHY IS THIS BEING BROUGHT
IN?
REMEMBER, THIS WHOLE ISSUE OF
THE
THIS PROCESS.
HE SAID HE WANTED A DEAL.
>> Greg: HE FOUND HER BEFORE
HE GOT KNOCKED DOWN --
>> Juan: WAIT A MINUTE --
THE FACTS ARE THAT THIS DEAL HAS
BEEN EXPANDING.
THERE WERE TWO CONTINUING
RESOLUTIONS DONE IN DECEMBER ON
THE PREMISE THAT WE WILL MAKE A
DEAL IN JANUARY.
>> Jesse: THE DEADLINE WAS NOT
FOR A WHILE THERE THEY ARE
TRYING TO ATTACH THIS TO THE
BUDGET.
>> Juan: YOU KEEP SPENDING
THIS
THIS.
EVERYBODY COMES TOGETHER AND
SAYS YOU THINK WE'VE GOT THIS.
COME BACK MR. PRESIDENT.
THEY COME BACK WITH A DEAL, A
BIPARTISAN DEAL.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS --
>> Jesse: WRONG!
THERE IS NO TEXT -- THERE'S
NOTHING TO VOTE ON!
THERE IS NO BAIL!
THEY CAN'T VOTE ON SOMETHING
THAT'S --
>> Juan: WHEN THEY CAME BACK
>> Juan: YOUR WAY OF DEALING
WITH THINGS IS TO SHOUT, YOU ARE
VERY MUCH LIKE TRUMP.
TRUMP IS THE ONE REPUBLICANS
CANNOT EVEN TRUST.
HE'S THE ONE WHO SAYS, YEAH, DO
NOT PUT CHIP IN THE BILL, DON'T
DO THAT.
>> Juan: REPUBLICAN SENATORS
ARE ON THE RECORD SAYING WE
DON'T HAVE ANY RELIABLE
LEADERSHIP OR DIRECTION COMING
FROM THIS WHITE HOUSE.
>> Dana: WANT TO KNOW A LITTLE
POINT OF HISTORY?
MY FIRST DAY ON THE JOB ON
THE FIRST GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN IN
1995.
>> Kimberly: I HOPE YOU'RE NOT
CALLING IT RIGHT NOW...
>> Greg: WE SHOULD HAVE
ANOTHER CLOCK.
SEE THIS CLOCK RIGHT HERE?
FOR THE NEXT SHUTDOWN.